good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy the Thursday hope
everyone's having a great day I know I
am because
I just am because I was born as Jackie
O's sister and really truly honestly who
could ask for more in this lifetime Jax
that's so sweet you're low-key always
having a great day except for the days
when you're not and that's one thing
about me I'm Dynamic and you really
never know what to expect but you really
do always open with optimism and hope
for the day and I think that's a really
important message for people it's also
important to note that when I say I'm
having a great day like I'm not always
having a great day but like this show
emulates positivity if I just got on
here like really told everyone what I
was thinking
no I understand it is a great day it's a
beautiful day here unfortunately turdy
and I have been separated just for uh
today's episode because we're doing
Audio Only I'm taking it a little bit
easier this week I feel like I was doing
a lot and so I I was on like modified
bed rest and now I'm on like more bed
rest than before everything's okay I
just like I felt like I was doing the
most and there was literally no need
um so we're doing Audio Only which won't
affect most of you I think the person
who it affects most is turdy no and like
one thing about struggles with audio
only one thing about me but today like
I'm not complaining like the fact that I
didn't have to put on makeup and do my
hair I really can't put into words how
grateful I am so don't worry about turdy
turdy's fine you know it's not even
turdy it's eye turdy it's the I.T
Department that lives inside of me
that's always like wait camera I'm gonna
get the studio the lights let me bring
it to your house like I'm okay I'm I'm
really kind of getting tired of doing
the most let's be real
but I do feel like next week you're
gonna be wanting to be on camera again
because you're like Glam turdy you're in
your Glam era yeah no I think uh
everything is still up and up in the air
I want you to just take it easy like
every time you're like walking around
like gives me anxiety just like sit the
[__] down so I'm happy to do audio only
maybe I'll go into Studio next week like
two or three times with like the usual
Ben if he's available Taylor's truck or
if she's available but Jackson Claude
original recipe I kind of love
um you I don't know why I'm gonna be
like so like really honest right now
please what do you love I love doing
audio only for one reason and that's
because sadly we don't upload to Youtube
but that does mean there's no comment
section so like I can say the most
[__] out of pocket [__] and there's
really nowhere for people to like gather
and be like we should call Claudia's
place of work and tell them what she
said yeah call me up call me up and tell
her what I said if I'm the I.T
Department you're HR for sure except we
do upload the audio to YouTube so there
is a comment section but it's not as
Lively no it's not as Community oriented
as when there's video by the way that's
like a new thing we started doing when
we um started doing Audio Only just like
putting just the audio on YouTube I
totally forgot that there actually is a
comment section and now that I've made
this conversation they're gonna make
they're gonna Galvanize all right I'll
reel it in today I won't say anything so
[__] crazy yeah for sure except how
it usually goes is that like they're
calling up my place of work and they're
calling you and dming you being like the
show would be better without Jackie
don't you think and I just want to say
like to everybody who has sent me that
message and it's not a lot of people
first of all like seriously and I mean
this like from the depths of my soul go
[__] yourself like seriously go
literally [__] yourself two uh it ain't
happening it ain't happening it's
Jackson Claude till we're 97. so
seriously go [__] yourself
and then [__] all the way off you dumb
[__] I love that for us thank you God
for always having my back so that's what
happens when you call my boss that's the
message You're Gonna Hear yeah no I'm
I'm not here for the Jack slander like I
don't know what they think they're doing
and they think they're like Galvin I
said I'll be like um maybe I should get
rid of my sister like as if I could even
get rid of you you're like older than me
how like let's say I seriously like
didn't want to work with you anymore
like how
yeah no it would be a really big thing
but also like I don't think either one
of us could
take the toast like if you wanted to
stop working with me like you'd have to
go start a different show no for sure
like it's literally like call her
actually no call her daddy like one of
them we couldn't we couldn't take it
yeah we'd be in court for years years
and years and years
yeah but speaking of sisters replacing
sisters yesterday Satchel stood in for
me I had a doctor's appointment
yesterday so I was like in the waiting
room just like listening to the episode
just like being a toaster which was
really fun
um but I didn't get to finish like
what's going on with the satch let's
let's recap such as episode
I mean honestly it was everything like
it was just more down time with satch
she looked so cool if you watched on
YouTube you saw she like showed up in a
cool girl outfit I Louis V tank top
she's in her classy era and I just want
to say like I wish one day I can go and
kiss Sophia Richie grange on the mouth
for inspiring these former thoughts to
look classy my sister included you're so
right like now like the like the cool
girls are dressing elegant they're
dressing a little modest they're
dressing like granny they're wearing
trousers they're wearing Cardigans
they're wearing flats like it's a
beautiful thing to see no it's really
like a full circle moment you're so
right that like we have Sophia Richie to
thank for the unthodification of the
satchelor the unthatification of America
of the of gen Z honestly and I think
it's gonna be like a slow rollout it's
just starting but like you even saw
Kylie wearing like her classy
Silhouettes I think this is the
beginning of a beautiful Trend that is
positively impacting my eyeballs our
family and our family no you're so right
Jacks I like analysis I saw what snitch
wore to dinner last night she was
wearing like the Spanx trousers that you
and I have loved but like World women
and cardigan and flat and she just looks
so classy yeah I I feel like I love this
but like even for my own personal style
like this very kind of coastal
grandmother like rich older woman
aesthetic I love and I feel like older
chubby girls have been dressing that way
forever for a multitude of reasons but
now that it's like in Trend it's
fabulous
yeah it's really fabulous like a little
mystery I don't need to see butt cheek
on the street yeah chunks of cheek
chunks I don't need it you don't I don't
need it well we have a fabulous show
today because it's just like me and you
and it's me and you and that's my whole
world the whispering down the hallway
she's a bad bad girl
um but I also have so much TV to recap
we're obviously gonna do the Vanderpump
Rules part two reunion at the TV recap
at the end of the show we do have a
story about Ted lasso yes we do so I'll
give my thoughts because I watched the
finale last night and you can take your
airpods out because obviously I am going
to spoil it that's fine I will watch
eventually I'm in no rush and I'm also
like not watching Ted lasso for the
riveting plot yeah yeah yeah it's not
like Game of Thrones but yesterday I
watched you did too yeah the ice
actually when I was at the eras concert
um with Paige disorbo she was the one
who was like what are you we were
talking about TV and she was like you
should watch the smartless podcast and I
was like no it's like not my podcast
she's like no they did like a
documentary on HBO like a TV show of
their podcast tour so I was like oh that
actually does sound interesting and it's
so crazy how I literally know nothing
about smartless even though they're the
biggest podcasts literally the biggest
comedy podcast for sure and like we're
honestly I think of them as our peers
our competitors
I knew nothing about them literally yeah
I might have been able to tell you who
the three guys are but I couldn't have
told you I I might have been able to say
Jason Bateman and I think I would have
said Will Arnett and I think I might
have said even the guy from Will and
Grace but I wouldn't have known his name
I still don't know his name other than
Sean Sean Hayes I think Sean Hayes yeah
that sounds right I found it so
interesting I will say like their comedy
like their shtick they have a huge
audience I don't think it's like my
necessarily type of Comedy so I did find
it like a little repetitive just a
little bit but I found like the neuroses
of so many of these like older
successful men like who have to travel
and have their meals together and try
and like driving long car rides together
I found it really interesting like who
knew Jason Bateman was literally like an
almond mom
literally like with his salads and like
he had his big salad for dinner and the
other guys got steaks and then he's up
all night like eating skinny pop and
prunes and that's just because he's not
full from his elements like if you just
had a stick like the other guys like you
wouldn't be snacking all night Jason
definitely has like some sort of
disordered eating it's yeah so it's
honestly I feel like food and meals
occupy all of my time like I'm always
thinking about what am I eating what did
I just eat did I eat too much did I not
eat enough they take it to another level
and I do think it's part of their [__]
but I think at least for Jason like it
is so real
yeah no they're always talking about
their next meal their past meal there
and their current meal and they're
planning their next meal while they're
eating their current Meal which is so
relatable like that's us that's
literally the good guys podcast yeah I
just like wouldn't have expected it from
the three of them who just seemed like
tall glasses of water who just like eat
when they're hungry and then don't eat
when they're not hungry no completely it
was eye-opening it was very funny I
don't understand the black and white
style choice I thought at first I
thought once they got on stage it would
be like in color and it's like the
documentary really starts I'm not like
living for black and white but that's
just because I'm like toxically modern
like we have color TV why would we not
use it it's unnecessary yeah
but I agree it's a really cool concept
especially for podcasters like us to
watch them do their thing and like to
see the success that they're having but
one thing that I thought was silly is
like they're going they're staying in
like these amazing hotels and they're
flying private and the crowds are so big
and they're acting like this is their
first taste of Fame and it's like they
are on some of the biggest shows in
television history like I can't imagine
wait that this podcast success is like
more than anything they've ever
experienced before we not me just
realizing that Will Arnett and Jason
Bateman were on Arrested Development
together that's how they know each other
yeah I totally forgot but she doesn't
even like he's in Ozark which obviously
I don't watch but Zach does so it's it's
a big one and it's really big it's like
it's probably one of his biggest
projects yeah they're all really big so
like this they're like oohing and awing
over all these things I'm like you've
been at this level of success for like
20 years no and something I found really
interesting was as somebody who like
goes on tour and knows the logistics of
like money
I don't know how after they fly private
they stay in the presidential suite
everywhere they go they have literally
15 people who work for them Margarita
who's always running out to get Gas-X
and sugar-free Red Bull
um and then they split the revenue three
ways they made no money from this tour
but they made money from this
documentary yes I thought the same thing
like that's not how comedians or
podcasters travel even Comedians and
podcasters who play huge theaters which
they're doing
yeah theaters know that you know if it's
stadiums Arenas yes but the size
theaters that they're doing just like
based on the numbers it kind of doesn't
add up no and like okay if they're doing
theaters like that like I feel like uh
let me think of a a comedian like
honestly like like a Jim Gaffigan would
go to DC and play that theater every
night for a week
and then he can fly private because it
makes sense financially I was just like
so focused on the the finances they
travel in style and there's nothing
wrong with that when you think about all
the people they're paying to be on the
tour with them and then they're
splitting all the revenue three ways and
then flying private and like there's a
million Vans for everyone I don't know
it something wasn't adding up
financially
yeah so maybe it's not like a financial
exercise for them and more of
I have no idea well I think also there
um I was really thinking a lot about
this because I'm so interested in the
business of podcasting I believe their
podcast is like owned or their deal is
with wondery which is owned by Amazon
and I'm sure that when they did that
deal they got a payout of you know
six maybe seven figures that they all
split so maybe like Amazon paid for the
tour I don't know
what a new show be on Amazon
exclusive to Amazon no no but they do
all like the the distributions why
wouldn't they do oh sorry they're this
new show I thought you meant their
podcast
um good question but also like
there's there are so many questions
maybe Amazon like got them a plane yeah
but even if Amazon owns their podcast do
they then collect the revenue from their
live show
I don't know we'd have to look at their
deal points I'm just fascinated by this
one and also like the revenue for the
theater size that we saw like
that was probably like like in a in that
DC theater how many seats you think that
was they probably make more money from
one episode of ads duh smartless yeah
right so like maybe this is like some
sort of branding thing for them well
honestly why I really liked it is I feel
like it's so legitimized podcasting and
podcast touring like to get like a whole
ass HBO documentary like that's so legit
yeah no it was cool yeah
um and then yesterday also in terms of
content I just wanted to shout out our
last episode uh that we just posted on
patreon it went up yesterday is
something I've been asked to do many
times that I just like I'm kind of
ashamed of but yesterday I was just like
[__] it we're posting it
um I did it like a uh like a literal
um you know what do they call it uh
guide guide but like you know those
yellow books like for dummies oh smut
for dummies I'm always getting asked
like hey just about smart
recommendations like how do you get into
smut what are your favorite like sexy
books how do you know when they're good
which authors are good so I did like a
breakdown of all the smut books I've
read most of the ones that I've read I
didn't get into Colleen Hoover because I
felt like that was like a little too
basic everyone knows yeah and that's
really not smart once you actually get
into smut like you see Colleen's like
doing the least when it comes to this
month
um so I gave like a full breakdown with
like pictures book covers ratings in
terms of plot ratings in terms of smut
um people are loving it they're saying
like really that I'm out here doing the
Lord's work and they were like you know
just really grateful that I did this so
patreon.com toast for turdies guide to
smut
turdy's guide to smut I love that I
actually have some two book things to
say one new episode of the redheads drop
today it's the first Thursday in June
our new episode drop we recorded it last
week so I've been like sitting on it for
a week and I've actually been really
excited because it's such a fun funny
episode this book just gave us so much
to chat and laugh about you know a lot
of loose ends but also beautiful moments
like it was just really sweet and also
and not to spoil the end of the episode
but Becky is choosing our next book and
she told us how she chose it and I think
it's like a life hack that everyone
needs to know she used AI she put into
AI like books that she loves and she was
like kid recommend similar books so
we're reading truebiz by Sarah novik
next book she had put in like where the
Crawdad sing like those really good like
literary novels
um that's so sad that are that are also
like really popular so that's where you
should get your next book recommendation
from well let's see let me see if the
redheads get [__] like like let's see
if everybody likes his book first and
then if it worked oh my God I'm never
not doing that isn't that genius because
I'm always like give me a book that's
like it ends with us or whatever right
yeah I'm always like asking for book
recommendations based on a previous book
so if I say like literally when people
ask like what my real like genre of
choice is like I loved Eliza starts a
rumor it was like just life you know
Suburban mom dumb drama but like
hilarious and I'm always like what's a
book like Liza starts a rumor ask chat
that is really a very very smart thing
go backs
go backs and then also I finished my
book last night the makeup Darlings I
need you to finish it because I need to
talk to you about it like I don't know
if I'm just being like negative negative
critical or because I remember after I
finished hunting wives like I didn't
love it so much but then you loved it so
much it made me like it more so I need
to know what you think about this one
okay I have started it so hopefully I'll
finish it this weekend and we can talk
about it
cool can't wait to chat with my garly
um and speaking of chatting with our
garlies we've got lots to dive into I
can't wait to talk about the Vanderpump
reunion
um
so
so without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
the Kardashians on Hulu you can watch
the all new season of the Kardashians
new episodes are dropping Thursdays only
on Hulu the world's most famous
matriarchy is back for the most intimate
look yet inside the family Empire so
this season we know a lot of what's
going to go down it seems really juicy
and they're really doing a good job of
striking a balance between their
extremely successful lives as business
women but also they're very real
personal lives that are just weirdly a
part of their business so there's gonna
be a lot of a lot of Entrepreneurship
sibling rivalry Newfound love oh
hopefully a businessman bow in the mix
family growth juggling business
motherhood family and more we already
got the first episode or to make a two
episodes already now
episode two dropped last night oh my God
okay so I'll catch up on that tonight
before tomorrow
um so two episodes in there's lots
there's you know a thunder is is a bruin
something is brewing between the girlies
specifically Courtney and Kim and I
can't wait to see how that unfolds I
just can't wait to see all the girlies
back you know we've got them all we've
got Chris we've got Courtney we've got
Kim we've got Chloe as Andy Cohen likes
to call her Kendall and Kylie I love
this show it's just a good good vibe
show it's really fun to watch I love
seeing the sisters they're so fabulous I
just love seeing like their homes and
their cars and their planes even the
most boring episode of the Kardashians
is better than literally any episode of
any other reality TV show so
don't miss season three of the
Kardashians new episodes drop Thursdays
only on Hulu if you're waiting up then
you guys already saw it last night
because it comes out on Wednesday nights
at midnight I haven't seen it yet I'm
really excited to see it but make sure
you're catching season three of the
Kardashians new episodes are dropping
Thursdays only on Hulu today's episode
is also brought to you by one skin if
you've ever thought to yourself what
could we well if we could reverse the
root cause of aging and then listen
closely our new sponsor oneskin puts
science and research first they were
founded by a team of four female PhD
level longevity scientists with over 15
years of experience one skin set out to
not just decrease the visible signs of
aging skin but to treat the root causes
of why skin ages so they're essential
face moisturizer their eye topical
supplement to firm and their topical
body supplement keep your body
moisturized so skin doesn't just look
younger and healthier it functions like
younger and healthier looking skin I
have to say I love their topical body
supplement I feel like everyone's always
talking about like skin aging on their
face for sure but especially because I
have like heavy set chest my neck and
like decolletage area I'm so conscious
of when it comes to aging I don't want
like wrinkles or fine lines so I love
that they have a product for that the
topical body supplement I've been using
it I love it their products are
formulated with their os01 peptide as
the primary active ingredient so it
supports the skin ability to resist the
effects of Transit intrinsic and
extrinsic aging factors their Flagship
product the os01 face is clinically
proven to strengthen the Skin Barrier
and it improves key skin Health markers
meaning signs of aging are significantly
diminished for a limited time you can
get 15 off one skin with our code toast
at oneskin.co they're the world's first
skin longevity company they address skin
Health at the molecular level targeting
the root causes of Aging so skin behaves
feels and appears younger it's time to
get started with your new face eye and
body routine at a discounted rate today
get 15 off with you the code toast at
oneskin.co that's 15 off with one skin
at oneskin.co that code is toast we only
have one body one skin and only you can
choose to make it better age healthy
with one skin
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
first story news that I never thought I
would report sex in the city's shocker
Kim Cattrall will be returning as
Samantha Jones to and just like that for
one night only the sex and City universe
will be whole again variety has learned
that Kim Cattrall will reprise her
iconic role as Samantha Jones in the
season two finale of and just like that
that title will just like never roll off
the tongue ever ever ever
she will only appear in one scene
according to sources she shot her
Dialogue on March 22nd in New York City
without seeing her speaking with the
star of the series The Stars including
Sarah Jessica Parker or with the
showrunner Michael Patrick King in the
scene she has moved to London and she'll
have a phone conversation with Carrie
and so she didn't really have to
interface with anyone
but we are getting some Samantha so I
will say this news like sounds better
than it is
um because once you actually read it you
know she's not actually filming with the
women it's a phone call it's in the
finale and it's one scene so it sounds
better than it is having said that like
I welcome this hopefully this is like an
intro because I watched all of and just
like that and I have to say like I'm a
hater to my core and it was cringe it
was problematic like it had all these
things but at the end of the day like I
did like it like I looked forward to the
episodes like there's just something
about the writing there's something
about these characters it's good like
I'm sorry I'm
I'm just gonna be honest like I liked it
okay and I feel like I don't want to
keep that in anymore so you're saying uh
because you like it
it's exactly what I'm saying Jackie but
there was this like glaringly obvious
thing missing and it was Samantha she
was Far and Away the best character her
she was so [__] real like she was
just saying [__] nobody would say but
she was [__] right about everything
like she was so sorely missed so
getting her back is great again it's
really not getting her back she's not
going to be a recurring role it's one
Cameo she doesn't even interact with the
other ladies but I think it's a step in
the right direction and for her I mean
Best of Both Worlds like she's getting
out for sure a huge payday because it's
the only way they would have brought her
back She [__] hates these people
um and she doesn't have to see these
[__] so like for her she's laughing
running to the bank and honestly I think
her kind of being like mysteriously
absent from this
uh
revamp whatever you want to call it
Reunion Show whatever it's called it's
so good for her and her character
because it just makes people appreciate
and miss her honestly yeah I think this
is all good of course one scene it's not
enough
um give us more I don't even watch the
show but um and she's a part of the
reason like I I don't think I would
watch even still like it's just not of
the utmost importance to me but like
certainly not without Samantha because
she really was the best but I do feel
like one like now contracts have been
signed and and doors are open and it
will be easier to to do another scene I
feel like who knows what happens in that
finale conversation it could be like a
cliffhanger that gets us to season three
where Samantha's back you know what I
mean well in season one Carrie and
Samantha were texting so Samantha wasn't
like dead like she was still like
technically in the show but we never saw
her because she was just texting with
Carrie right no but like the fact that
Kim is on the scene like this could be
it could be just what it is one scene
but it could also be opening the door
for season three with Samantha yeah but
I'm saying season one with the text
messages like it was all very
cliffhangery they were like we'll see
wishing right but there was no actual
Kim participation no now that we have
Kim participation it opens the door to
more
yeah what I think is also that's
exciting it is what I also think is
interesting about this show it's like
they are unable to keep anything under
wraps that's a because they film in New
York so like people are just always
seeing like new characters show up like
they're unable and I feel like HBO's so
good at that like with you know the
ending of Game of Thrones like I don't
it's obvious I think partially is
intentional it's good for like the show
hype but this would have been
um like a huge
amazing spoiler
yeah but I feel like they're
intentionally putting stuff out I don't
know about this one but like they put
out the picture of Carrie and Aiden
kissing I also think over the years
they've filmed fake scenes to throw
people off yeah
I guess that's also what's great about
the show like it's so New York they
literally they've never filmed on like a
a studio a lot like they're always in
the streets and that really is what
makes it like so authentically in New
York and and I think that's like a huge
reason why people like it yeah but they
could also be having like pivotal
conversations and scenes like indoors
indoors yeah close the window but I
think that they like this hype machine
like you know Game of Thrones doesn't
need that like oh a brand was spotted
sitting on the throne what does it mean
or like but for this show like it is
very much a part of the Zeitgeist tip
for people to speculate about what's
gonna happen so I think that they're in
on that yeah no that's that's fair
that's fair it's just interesting but I
did hear Brad was spotted sitting I
heard that too I read grapes like a
little mad king no I heard he was at the
pub
making making deals Wheeling dealing
yeah he was just like knocking him back
with the night King
literally
okay well are you ready for our next
story yeah
it's a yawn for me but I think people
care Leonardo DiCaprio dined with 28
year old British model nilam Gill and
his mom so Leo took a break from
partying to enjoy a night out with a
group of Pals including British model
nilam Gill and his mom in photos
obtained by Page Six he could be seen
keeping a low profile as he left the
children Firehouse in London on Tuesday
his mom was also exiting the venue with
him while uh nilam Gill followed behind
I mean that's just [__] weird like
literally
um
his mom could be literally this girl's
grandmother
they literally look like a family three
generations of DiCaprio's grandmother
son and daughter yeah I mean I guess
that means that he's dating this person
because like all signs point two but I
feel like every single week it's someone
else that he's dating the same like
literally this age yeah
and okay cool you know this story is
like so fatigued I'm not like you know
being kept up like who's Leo spotted
with it was interesting when he was
spotted with Gigi Hadid because that was
different that was like somebody who um
is a mother and has like a successful
business and like doesn't need Leo
there's not like a power Dynamic
um that was interesting but beyond that
like just this gaggle of carbon copies
of different like it's just it's so
uninteresting to me it's so uninspired
yeah he also goes out now all the time
in a hat and a face mask I think he was
at like a sports game wearing a mask and
now he's at this restaurant I don't know
if he does it for like anonymity but
like it's not working he definitely does
it for anonymity and I just want to say
he seems to care about the environment
so much masks are so bad for the
environment I'm just saying Trails Greta
Greta would definitely be wearing like a
reusable cloth he's wearing these like
disposable plastic lines right but the
thing about the reusable cloth is that
that actually does nothing so we might
as well breathe fresh clean air that's
true that's true I mean I don't I
honestly like I don't think Leo if he's
running to like events and games I don't
think he's like really still concerned
with the pandemic I think this is
definitely like an anonymity thing
yeah but it's like not [__] working
like the camera is in his face yeah no
like they're gonna photograph you
whether you're wearing a mask or not so
maybe maybe he's feeling insecure about
like a nose job lip filler
yeah yeah no that's you're on to
something their sister that to me like
would be more understandable than
whatever I'm looking at that is
definitely a possibility Leo went under
the knife
Leah was feeling insecure maybe Leo's
nose has been bothering him his whole
life and he finally just like took his
life took charge yeah or he had a
deviated septum sure
sure sure are you ready for our next
story which is also some new rumored
couple news sure
Erica Jane has been spotted with an
older gentleman who also then just
posted on Instagram like a photo of him
and his wife he's married he's married
but he filed for like a separation in
2021. oh or they were anyways Erica Jane
was spotted on a quote-unquote date
earlier this week but it didn't look
necessarily like a date they were in
Caesar's Palace walking around she
looked fire flames like yeah she
definitely looked like she wasn't not
trying but it could also be a couple of
friends
but a rep confirmed to US Weekly that
they're not dating that Jim is her
lawyer and family friend for over 20
years he's been her primary attorney for
some time now he said I'm trying to help
my friend and people want to see
something nefarious and that and they
want to impose a sexual relationship I
don't want to see anything nefarious
Blake what are you doing in Vegas with
your lawyer well she is doing a
residency in Vegas
true so she's like a work thing maybe
they he came to support like I see my
lawyer all the time like I don't think
I think this could have been a date but
them explaining like he's a family
friend and a lawyer and honestly that's
more than enough for me I think a lot of
people see her with an older gentleman
and assume she's like looking for her
next time Girardi when we get our hopes
up who isn't but I know that's kind of
I'm honestly like acknowledging like my
own bias right now and how much I want
this to be true and it's just not no I
mean let's just be real like we saw
Erica's life with Tom and we saw Erica's
life without Tom like they're different
and I'm sure she wants to get back to
that place like she wants a palace for
the chapel like she has a certain
standard of living and her little
Bungalow in West Hollywood like it's
nice but I don't think it's gonna cut it
forever
but I also yes like you want to see her
get back to
the things that she loves but I also do
really
Envision her with kind of an older man
and not some of these like boy toys that
I imagine she's like running around with
like I don't think I think she needs
someone who can be on her level she's
very smart and mature and sophisticated
and like so when I see her with someone
who's like a successful mature King King
I'm like that works for me yeah no if
the day comes where Erica Jane does
settle down like I'm fully picturing a
Tom 2.0 I'm not looking for like maybe
like a Silicon Valley billionaire Young
when I was younger yeah not some like
not an Instagram model love Island
contestant no no she definitely has a
type and I will say like obviously her
and Tom's marriage was a marriage of
convenience but I do and I I did and I
still do really think like when it was
good like I think she really did love
him I don't think it was you know like a
complete arrangement
yeah at least from her book like I was
convinced what did she say in the book
she had the only the nicest things to
say I mean obviously he was still her
husband but just like the way that he
took care of her and protected her and
was so smart and gave her advice like
all of those things were why she was so
attracted to him as an older gentleman
oh yes yeah also she's 51 now so like if
she's gonna go with someone her age or
older like that is going to be a 60 year
old gentleman so when I see her with a
silver fox I'm like that could be he
could be the one no in my mind she's
like such like a reality star influencer
pop star I feel like she's 32. but she's
like she's a uh she's a woman she's an
older woman
yeah well she looked sickening just
walking around Caesar's Palace do you
see the outfit I did she's been like
slaying
um the looks yeah she looks great I feel
like she's in a really good place like
this whole thing is now like officially
behind her and I feel like in this
upcoming season when she's filming like
it's no longer a conversation like I
think she's really out of it yeah which
and that must be the best feeling in the
world for something that probably kept
her up at night for two years straight
yeah and also like she couldn't really
have a a voice on the show outside of
Defending herself and talking about all
the allegations and like she's weathered
this storm and I'm excited for her to
just be herself again and live her life
and be the Erica that we know and love I
agree because we like I feel like I even
forget like pre
-divorce Erica like she was everything
and then she kind of became the worst
but like she was loud she was going
through a hard time
um so I'm ready for her to like be the
best again like sniper from the side
yeah no and I definitely like in the
last few years have faltered in my
stanhood same but I'm I'm I'm tabula
Ross saying I'm not like going back like
you know it's it's a constant involving
thing but now I do feel like with all
the legal stuff behind her like tabula
rasa I look forward to the future I
couldn't have said it better myself
tabula rasa what does that mean clean
table Clean Slate clean slate
yeah I Latin I'm also definitely like
interested in what's happening in
Beverly Hills I feel like it's awfully
quiet that's what I wanted to say I saw
like a meme or a tweet that was like
this is the first season that we have no
idea what's going on in Beverly Hills
it's also the first season without Rina
yeah in a while right so the question is
was lit we're not just like leaking
everything or is there nothing going on
without Rena I think Rena was leaking
everything yeah I mean that's like the
obvious answer because I think things
are dead like some things going on even
if it's not
you know Kathy Hilton having a breakdown
in the club like right there's things
you know for the last like three or four
seasons like we always know what's gonna
happen because it gets like we're always
talking about it while they're filming
it and it's like a spoiler no that's
very interesting you know what that is
interest it's interisant I agree I just
I think it's interesting
another interest on fact wait is our
next story yep
so the succession ending that we didn't
see Jeremy Strong who plays Kendall Roy
revealed the quote explosive show had a
shocking alternate finale that he
improvised so the headline is like of
course he did just listen like I can
with this story
succession star Jeremy Strong has
revealed a shock alternate ending to the
show which concluded in spectacular
Style on Sunday the actor who plays
Kendall Roy spoke to Kara Swisher on the
official succession podcast about his
improvisation of his character's final
scene in which he attempted to jump into
the river unbeknownst to cast and crew
so Kendall had his dreams crushed when
shiv stopped him from becoming CEO
Jeremy who has spoken in the past about
his method acting revealed he actually
climbed the railings to inch his way
into the water before he was saved by
Colin his minder who was previously his
father's driver he said quote I stood up
and walked slowly to the barrier that
was set up there and climbed over it and
I didn't really know what I planned to
do and the actor playing Collins saw me
and ran and stopped me from doing it
so I have to say I don't think that
would have been a terrible ending and I
definitely thought when he was like
walking so depressed by the water I'm
like what is he gonna do because we saw
him like two seasons ago like really
struggling mental health-wise I think he
like tried to drown himself or something
like there was there is that history so
not only do I think that wouldn't have
been a bad like
ending I think it would have been on
track I thought it was gonna happen yeah
I think it would just be have been like
more overt yeah for the show you know
we're nothing like really happens also
he was he didn't he didn't jump in it
would just be like Colin bringing him
down which is actually so Kendall and so
Colin and so Colin but then Jeremy said
I mean I'm sure Jessie's choice is
better like the choice not to air that
and in a way I think you see the
intentionality in the character I mean
you said you felt like he was going to
go in right and I did I tried to it's a
completely tragic ending from my
perspective I think that Jesse maybe
intended that in the writing this sense
that Kendall has lost but maybe he's
free right like with everyone's ending
like we're supposed to extrapolate what
happens next like Roman is sitting at
the bar getting wasted like that's
obviously the path he goes down Kendall
is like wandering around aimlessly in
the middle of the day like by by Cliffs
and you're like yeah for sure like
you're supposed to just assume
yeah but
I actually don't think it's in Kendall's
character too
um
to actually go through with it no no no
no no no no no no
right but also I've been seeing some
stuff about Romans ending like one he
ordered a martini which is Jerry's drink
whatever that means
and two like he sips it and he smiles
for a second and then he's like somber
again so everyone said we should give
him an Emmy for that
um
like I'm not even kidding like that's
what the tweets were and so I I know I
he's like happy he's not unhappy with
the situation I have to say succession
Twitter is one of the most deeply unwell
spaces and corners of the internet like
people like it's a good show but it's
not it's not even a good show but like
they take it so [__] serious and they
love this is like the new thing that
I've seen because I've just seen people
saying this about Ted lasso because
there's like a lot of people saying this
season of Ted last so like kind of
stings
um like you were saying it but Rolling
Stone just wrote like critics are saying
it yeah I say it about everything right
right no we are like cool haters to our
core but like when other people say it
we're like oh yeah okay and everyone is
like people just don't get it like they
don't get success you're like oh you
don't like each other you don't get it
which is my like the most [__]
condescending retort to like my opinion
like I'm the last time I have my [__]
opinion [__] off and you know what it's
TV it's not mathematics like if you have
to get it so hard maybe just maybe it's
not [__] good
yeah facts and like I got season one and
season two right it's like what changed
so with season three it's just like
above my yeah right like me oh am I
getting Dumber or is this show just not
good like where's the show getting
Dumber I hate that retort it's so first
of all Incorrect and it's so like moral
High Ground like oh you know God uh
you're so good song shut the [__] up so
true also something I wanted to talk
about with succession because everyone's
talking about the finale and I sent you
this article that the succession finale
had the highest rating views ever for
their show
series high of 2.9 Million viewers
the way that people talk about this show
like you would think it's like the Super
Bowl how many people watch like the
finale of Game of Thrones
I think like 20 million
damn let me Google it people watch by
the way like that's about a 2.8 million
that's literally how many people
watching rolls no literally it's oh yeah
Game of Thrones was 19.3 Million
um more people I think watch American
Idol than
succession but you would never know it
from the way it's talked about no
because it's so like um
highbrow like how many people watch
Yellowstone
I think 14 million oh
because but right you would think the
way people talk about both of these
shows like you would think like oh
succession probably has like a little
bit of a bigger audience than
Yellowstone no you would think it's just
one of the greats like one of the shows
like we're still talking about Game of
Thrones like it's it's a show in like
the TV Hall of Fame
uh 12 million people tuned in for the
premiere of season five of the
Yellowstone wow and so if and when it
ends that'll be even more yeah yeah yeah
yeah
interesting factoids I just find it
interesting
yeah but I'm still I'm Not Gonna Knock
succession because they gave me the best
outcome I could have asked for no and
really I do think it was the only way
the outcome like could have ended like
when you really think about it
like Matson was never keeping this
family
in the business like they're so toxic he
saw the worst of them when they went on
their Retreat like they're three deeply
unwell people like who the [__] would
meet them and be like yeah I want to
give business to these people like I
would run for the [__] Hills yeah
and then the the
concept that all three kids could get
along long enough to like vote together
is also impossible
it's so crazy to think about that like
they couldn't no and that's what we've
been seeing like they're so they betray
one another at like the lowest level
like they're not a family unit they're
not a united front so the sheer idea
that they would vote together they're
all too narcissistic too egotistical
like it was never gonna happen
it had to be Tom it's the same way it
had to be bran it had to be Tom
It could only be Brad It could only be
Tom
yeah and like people didn't like the
Game of Thrones finale because they're
like bran but then when you really
analyze it like it could only be bran
I guess
because the other two were too
problematic John and Daenerys
right well and Daenerys at that point
spoiler alert spoiler spoiler alert was
dead no we literally spoiled the show
saying brand brand right right right
right we spoiled the show 40 minutes ago
duh
are you ready for our fifth and final
Story another spoiler coming your way no
why is it the next story with another
spoiler coming your way that happens to
be brought to you by carry Uma
carry Yuma
uma uma
okay
Yuma the cool sustainable sneaker
company made for life on and off the
board warmer days are ahead and we all
need a staple shoe to carry us through
summer and Beyond so when it comes to
days spent in the sunshine and on your
feet carry uma's got you covered with
effortless style unmatched comfort and
premium quality worn by tons of celebs
including Jackson Claude which is really
kind of like the most famous people in
the planet I would say so Jax and I have
a bunch of sneakers from carry Uma I
pretty much exclusively wear sneakers
especially white ones in the summer I
just think it's like such a cool look
um and I like the Karima ones for a
multitude of reasons mostly because
they're really breathable and they're
super comfortable you can wear them for
long periods of time we've loved the
lace-up OCA for years but now carry Uma
recently launched canvas slip-ons
they're made with organic cotton and
natural rubber outsoles they're easy to
wear and they have a Timeless look with
Incredible comfort in ease jaggy loves
loves loves
a canvas slip-on shoe it's true all you
have to do is watch the last 30 episodes
of the toast on YouTube I'm wearing my
carry UMAS every single day they're so
cute a slide on sneaker I like the white
pair and they're so comfortable they
have the support that you need just in
life in general but also uh for a
pregnant lady for every pair of sneakers
sold carry them a plants two trees and
they've already planted over two million
trees to date
um they're dedicated and certified B
Corp for restoration uh programs based
in the Brazilian Rainforest so you know
that it's all good for a limited time
toast listeners can get an exclusive 15
off your pair of carium sneakers go to
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com toast for 15 off
that's
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com slash toast for 15 off
but only for a limited time today's
episode is also brought to you
by manscaped ladies June is just around
the corner and our guess is that you
haven't purchased a Father's Day gift
well look no further than the sponsor of
today's show because our friends at
manscaped are dedicated to upgrading his
grooming game from face to waste their
brand new beard hedger Pro kit is the
total package dedicated to making sure
all fathers go from dad to Daddy this
year have him join the 8 million men
worldwide who trust manscaped and of
course you can get 20 off and free
shipping with our code toast at
manscaped.com so Father's Day is coming
up whether you know your man's is a
father or your dad
um get a good gift get them something
that they'll actually use and you will
actually love so the ultimate Father's
Day via MVP is the beard hedger Pro kit
inside they have their beard hedger
trimmer beard shampoo and conditioner
beard oil beard bomb and two free gifts
with their signature beard comb and
scissors so you just buy the one kit and
you get like what did I just read like
six gifts it's everything that they
could need it comes in a really cute
case
if he doesn't have a beard he also can
try their performance package 4.0 so
it's a bundle that's definitely daddy
material it includes their signature
lawnmower a weed whacker ear hair and
nose trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant Revival toner boxer briefs and
the travel bag we all know that dads
love comfort so if grooming is already
dialed in make sure to hook him up with
the manscaped boxers get 20 off in free
shipping with code toast at
manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped.com code toast
make this Father's Day one he won't
forget with manscaped
thank you so much Claudia speaking of
beard our fifth and final story Ted
lasso finale Jason Sudeikis speaks on it
he says quote the story is done so
season three of Ted lasso just ended all
the episodes aired turdy has watched
them
Jason Sudeikis told
um Dana Carvey and David Spade on the
fly on the wall podcast that the story
is done quote it sounds like such a
political answer but it's the truth we
only conceived these three seasons then
this thing became this big old thing
yeah no I think if you watch the show
like there's as much as I think a lot of
people would like for it to just go on
forever because I think for a lot of
people it's a comfort show it's like you
know really all about like kindness and
positivity but it's still like very
funny and it would have been nice for
just the show to go on forever but they
clearly like had a start and an end and
I think when you can end a show in your
own terms it's like the best feeling and
you're not like another season and no
one's watching like to end on a high is
like such an accomplishment
um
and I think if you had told me last
season that the next season is going to
be the last I would have been sad but
after watching this like I didn't think
it was as good and he's right like the
story is over like once you watch you
know like the show can't go on
yeah and you'd never want to beat a dead
horse I think that even though it's hard
for the fans sometimes like there's
nothing worse than your favorite show
getting really bad and stupid and
pointless and boring so you met her like
leave out of high leave them wanting
more and it also does not that they've
said this in any way shape or form but
it does leave it open to bringing the
show back in a few years when you don't
kill it yeah yeah
so how was the rest of the season like
do you wanna tell us what happened
anything crazy do you want to take your
airpods out
I don't know I just like I don't know
that I'm gonna watch it in a timely
manner okay so you know they're what
have you seen any of this season
yeah what have you seen probably like
half
um they have that guy who's great
who the soccer player who's really good
oh Zava Zava okay Zava leaves and it's
like irrelevant and then the team is
just themselves and they're stinking it
up and then Ted lasso comes up with like
a a new strategy and they they start
wait so you're saying Ted lasso actually
coaches yes it was shocking that's a
twist
so he just comes up with like a new
strategy and they start killing it
they're winning they're winning they're
killing it
um so last night's episode was like the
finale they won the championship and it
was like really emotional but then it
turned out that like Manchester City
um also won so that like kicked them out
of the first spot but whatever they like
won all their games and it was like
sweet but of course they didn't like end
up making the next League
um
and Ted wants to leave Ted needs to go
back to Kansas City to be with his
family and he makes the decision and
like everybody supports him him and beer
go go back
um beard actually gets off the plane
because he's in love with Jane and so he
actually stays everything at the club
stays the same except Ted leaves
um except did you see yet that Nathan
the Wonder kid gets fired from
no West Ham he gets fired because oh my
God I can't wait to see Rupert like
takes him out for drinks and like brings
him like a prostitute but he has a
girlfriend now and he doesn't want to
cheat on his girlfriend so he leaves and
he literally gets fired for like not
[__] this girl
um and then he's like depressed and his
girlfriend's trying to get him out of
bed and all he wants to do is go back to
Richmond Richmond and like they bring
him back that was to me the Fatal
[__] flaw in the show they bring back
that little [__] and I know that's the
whole point of the show it's like about
forgiveness and kindness yada yada but I
couldn't in like the last two episodes
he's like he's the tower guy again
he doesn't become Ted's job
no Roy gets his job which is fabulous
okay that's better I thought like Nate
takes over for Ted that would be so
undeserving no it was so upsetting there
were a few things that the show tied up
nicely the first is that like Rebecca in
the earlier season did you see when they
went to Amsterdam and she like spent the
night with that guy
no she drops head off at the airport and
she runs into the guy and like this this
fortune teller had told her that she was
gonna have a family and he has a son and
like I mean he's a daughter and it was
like a nice ending wrapped up for
Rebecca nicely she thought about selling
the club since they were so valuable now
that they were so good it was worth two
billion dollars but she actually sold 49
of it to the community like everybody
like gotta share so like they all
started it was like really sweet I liked
that she's like philanthropic Queen
so some people wrapped up really nicely
like Ted goes back and I think they like
kind of they don't say but like Michelle
is getting really annoyed with her new
boyfriend like he's like so negative and
like I just don't think it's working and
then she's really happy when he gets
home so I think maybe there's a path
forward for Ted like and his family to
get back together which is nice oh
that's cute even though she like is the
worst the entire time that we've ever
watched a show
um but then some people wrapped up like
not so nicely like I didn't appreciate
them bringing Nathan back I thought that
was really not good
um but by far the biggest gripe I had
with the ending is like I kept waiting
for Roy and Keely to get back together
right and the last couple of episodes
he's like still clearly in love with her
and he's like really struggling he's
asking everyone for advice and Jamie is
still like really in love with Keely too
but Jamie and Roy are such good friends
they decide like you know what we're
both gonna fight for her but like we're
still gonna be friends and Keely wants
neither of them
she just wants to like keep being a
businesswoman and she works with Rebecca
to start like a female AFC Richmond and
yeah but why can't she also have a
boyfriend you know the two are not
mutually exclusive that's not like wrong
I literally that makes me mad wrong
she's wrong for that I'm sorry honestly
even towards the end obviously Roy is
like the number one but I was also like
shipping her and Jamie too because
Jamie's really have this like he fully
grew up he's a stark player but he's
such a good teammate and he's a good guy
no and I could see that but the problem
with Roy and Keely breaking up is that
there was nothing wrong with their
relationship like yeah it was so Random
even though why they broke up
um
so it's like it's not like Jamie could
provide or something like Rory and Keely
were perfect yeah it was so exciting
that makes me madder than Nate yeah no
that was the worst part she ended up
with nobody
why
why oh my God okay well
now I don't know if that makes me want
to watch more or less but thanks for the
recap I'm glad I know you're welcome and
I do think like it's it's good that it's
ending
yeah I think so too
all good things must come to an end
turdy Lou but I want to say one thing
one more thing I just looked at my notes
because I needed to remember
my biggest issue
with the show is that not once in the
final episode nor in the final season
did Danny Rojas say football is live
why
maybe like it was trademarked and they
were gonna get sued Danny Rojas is Far
and Away the best character he gets like
an even bigger role like all the
characters that you like know and love
like Trent Crim his book comes out you
know he's writing a book on the team yes
it's called the Richmond way
um
all the characters that like you slowly
start to get to know and really like
like Danny Rojas like Sam and I thought
maybe Sam and Rebecca were gonna end up
together but they didn't
um Trent cram they all get like happy
endings it's nice but like Danny Rojas
is the light of my life and I don't know
why he didn't say football is live
that's so funny that he has made such an
impact on you oh he's part of the reason
me and Ben like really loved the show
when we first started it oh that's so
sweet he was so sweet and so funny and
so cute and so nice football is live
nice and there's that much of an impact
on me there's a scene in the final
episode where like they get a penalty
kick they're down by one and Jamie's
like gonna take it but he gives the ball
to Danny Rojas he's like you got this
ma'am
and I thought I'm like oh my God he's
gonna literally kick it and say football
is live
and he didn't
that's weird yeah what happened to
football's life I don't know maybe you
could find like a forum of other people
all about it I'll look into it
um so that's your Ted lasso recap
yes and now it's time for Vanderpump
Rules recap so I want to say
I'm really like genuinely like I'm
trying not to be a hater because like
this is the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me but the fact that we got
through two entire whole episodes
without Raquel joining the group like
one is not enough we didn't need to with
Sheena we needed two with Raquel we got
like one and a half of each because she
sat down at 9 59. we got trailer Raquel
we got trailer Raquel in time we got
them outside of the trailer like half of
the episode was lunch
it doesn't count I know I agree but like
you also have to remember like it's
still Bravo and so even though they
didn't like make us wait till the third
episode to talk about scannable like
they are going to tease the [__] out of
everything and make us pay they're
selling like I wasn't like when I was
enjoying the episode I really and I I
really was enjoying Sheena
um and I wasn't like dying for her to
leave or anything but then when Raquel
comes out and the episode ends I hadn't
realized what time it was and I was like
oh that's [__] annoying no Sheena was
like giving her Platinum
vinyl to Andy at 9 43 and then they went
to a commercial break and then they went
to Raquel's one-on-one I was like oh
she's literally not sitting until 9 59
me and Ben were Ben was like so annoyed
it that snuck up on me I I didn't
realize I was acutely aware of the time
because I'm like I need this [__] to
sit down
a peak moment was
Ariana telling Andy that Raquel and Tom
are not sitting next to each other like
I kind of loved that
and he listened
because it is actually odd that they
didn't sit next to each other like it
would have been visually like crazy to
see her in between the toms yeah but
that's also so [__] disrespectful to
Ariana and like if we're all team Ariana
then like we can't put production ahead
of her feelings no it's very true
um I have like kind of an unpopular
opinion because I know a lot of people
are like confused and annoyed that like
Lisa Vanderpump is taking Tom's and of
all side and I don't think she is I just
think she's like
trying to get him like the the space to
speak because nobody will let him speak
and I actually am appreciative that
she's doing that because this whole
thing where like every time Tom says
something like eight people just descend
and he doesn't actually finish his
sentence like I want to hear what this
monster has to say like I'm curious
um I actually am appreciative Lisa
attempting to like regulate this
conversation I agree like it's not
productive if everyone jumps down his
throat and even when he's saying
something and everyone like immediately
just calls Matt like oh will you [__]
Raquel and it's like no we all know that
so like we're all listening to whatever
he's saying with that in mind like so
let him bury himself like we don't need
like and just I want to hear what this
actual sociopath has to say for himself
and like hear how he rationalizes
certain things and how he can judge and
critique others because if it was a
normal human being sitting there they
would just shut the [__] up only speak
when spoken to try and keep their head
down but I want to hear him pop off at
Lala about absolutely nothing to do with
him because it makes him look even
stupider because we all know what he did
no and like he was like saying stuff
that was like kind of interesting but
nobody could hear him because
everybody's screaming up like when he
said Lala pulled her IUD out the second
stats he got pregnant what does that
mean I have no idea please elaborate
sociopath but nobody heard him
yeah but like he has just no credibility
and also his credibility is so shot like
whether he's telling the truth or he's
telling a lie like we can just call it a
lie
of course no and that's the thing with
the um with the restraining order he
like swore that heard her say I punched
that [__] in the face and
Aria either Ariana is just like
protecting her friend as she should and
maybe she's lying because of the legal
case or Tom is lying honestly to me I
don't care whether uh Sheena Pancho like
yeah no but it matters to them
in this moment because in this moment
like two days later she has to go to
court and I'm sure she's actually really
scared yeah no it matters to them like
yeah I don't care whether or not like
morally if Sheena technically not sure
and also like we saw what
what it um amounted to on Raquel's face
so like I think we can all envision what
it was but if you want to call that a
punch a slap or a push like that's just
it makes it makes a difference legally
but it doesn't make a difference in
terms of like what our brains yeah
um yeah no I feel like there were times
when it's like Ariana's obviously the
victim the Vic no and she's also the
moral one in the relationship and I feel
like since Tom has lied so much and he
has literally no credibility and you can
just write off everything that he's
saying is a lie like it actually leaves
Ariana space to like also lie because no
one is going to believe him improvise
yeah no and it's like I literally don't
care if she's lying like she didn't tell
the big lie for eight months that you
did so right Katie and Tom were like
absent from this reunion I like well
because she buried him in one breath and
it was oh my God by the way most
beautiful thing I ever saw seriously I
don't think I've ever seen somebody clap
back at somebody
so seamlessly and so like funny you're
friends with everybody your serial
Killer's wet dream knowing she was like
you're gonna get yourself chopped up if
you keep up this behavior and it's so
true he's so trusting everyone's his
friend he prioritizes everyone over his
loyal wife of eight years like no yeah
go go go trust brilliant but I have to
say like Tom like being like kitschy
like I'm taking a Xanax like shut up
like I find him so infuriatingly stupid
I don't think anything he does is funny
like he's not cute to me anymore and
these little like oh look I brought a
prop shut up yeah shut up at least he is
pretty much shutting up yeah it's so
true because he's smart he's like I know
I'm in trouble so I'm literally not
gonna speak up I'm not speaking unless
spoken to because I don't want to like
cross my wires I don't want to say
something that contradicts something
else I said and he's also not a
psychopath like Sandoval like oh I'm in
trouble I'm gonna apologize and be small
and be very be small College like what's
the word um with a C
Kurt no like Khan
I don't know it'll come to me when this
episode's over no he's just he has to he
has to be weak
yes and just take it Tom's like fighting
back and it's like what are you trying
to prove that Ariana was worthy of being
cheated on by her best friend like in
what world are we ever going to get to
that conclusion but the fact that he
thinks that that is somewhere that we
might get to and that's where he's
trying to bring us yeah
is
beyond words like I really like I don't
care like how bad things were in your
relationship like it it all that context
all that color he wants means nothing no
like we'll never ever justify what he
did ever no ever we don't care he
doesn't get that no he doesn't he's
really trying to paint a picture I was
like he was this like forlorn boyfriend
who tried and tried and he got no
intimacy and no connection so he fell
into the arms of another vagina like we
don't care yeah we literally just okay
so all those things are true break up
with her when they like went into like
Lala's Randall thing like I so don't
care it's like so much has happened
since then like I literally forgot about
Randall and like of course I feel for
Lala and I know she's been through a lot
but in terms of like the storyline every
time they strayed away from Raquel I was
like come on
oh I felt the opposite I kind of needed
a breather and I also felt like every
other storyline does segue back to
scannable anyway because it it involves
everyone so I was okay to like deviate
for a second the only thing about Lala
and Randall is like I think a lot of it
is legal so when she talks about these
like horrible things he's a horrible
person like I think we have maybe 10 of
an idea of what she's talking about and
it's frustrating that we can't know more
but I understand that we can't so it's I
did that's why it was like literally a
90 second conversation yeah it was
really it was really quick I liked um
seeing Ali I actually really like Ali I
really like Ali too and as we said like
I just hope James can keep her I think
she's really smart and you can tell that
she is
like a fun cool girl because Katie and
Lala really like her yeah
I think she's a great gal I think she is
too and I really hope the best for them
and their relationship like really I'm
not even joking yeah but at this point
they've been together over a year mm-hmm
so
could be good I do think there's like a
part of her that like sought out being
on the show which I don't think is a bad
thing honestly
um like she was like you know she wanted
to be an entertainment journalist before
like and she watched random number like
I think part of her is into James for
what he provides agreed
but if that were the case she would have
made a bigger Splash on this season
that's true and been like thirstier and
just like getting into fights and and
starting stuff she did make a splash
with the whole Abbey thing but I don't
even think she knew what she was
stepping in no and she didn't even say
that to Katie on camera yeah so true
like I I think that actions speak louder
than previous words and she just was
James's girlfriend it's also really
interesting how like after they wrapped
filming this Raquel and Tom stuff like
didn't die down and there were all these
conversations being had like Sheena took
Ariana to lunch and was like by the way
like I'm like quaking no that was crazy
that like people had suspicions like
when this came out for us we were what I
couldn't I couldn't fathom anything so
crazy and I felt like that the cast felt
that way too but come to find out like
Lala lit like had was fully on to them
kd2 probably Sheena had enough suspicion
to take it to Ariana like Ariana knew
that this was a a thing
that was the craziest thing to me yeah
agreed
but I guess how could you not know that
it's not like they were even hiding it
that well no they were being so dumb and
like that's what Andy was saying like I
can't believe I forget who he said this
to maybe Raquel on the one-on-one like
how now watching the season back like
you guys were not even trying and I
actually thought what rock Kelson and
her one-on-one was actually interesting
that like her and Tom devised a plan
like Tom coached her on what to say and
then when Ariana did just call her and
was like Tom's not gonna tell me
anything like if you ever even for one
second cared about me tell me everything
and she did
yeah I feel of the two
Raquel is more remorseful even though it
appears like she doesn't
cry she has a weird way uh she but she's
a weird girl yeah the way that she
handles her processes or shows emotions
is not how people would expect her to be
acting right now but I also feel like
sometimes when she's asked a question
like I feel like when she's asked a
question she tells the truthful answer
you know what I mean like so Ariana
called her and like she gave all the
truths like I don't think she like sits
there and lies to her face but obviously
she had this whole second life going on
that no one knew about but if at any
time someone asks no I guess Sheena did
ask her yeah sorry Sheena did ask her
and she lied straight to her face I take
it back I just that's the thing it's
like now I have so many questions
they're all we've gotten not one answer
about Raquel like to me she's such a
mystery and I think after part two we
should have known a little bit more
yeah and about like where they stood in
their relationship right like what is
going on with them like that scene when
he said during lunch I loved that they
were filming during lunch these people
did not get five minutes off during this
day
um
when they were talking to each other in
the trailer it was very platonic it was
they were giving us nothing and then
they wanted to be off camera either
maybe so they could like you know
console one another and like combo the
game plan maybe even kiss I don't know
um and production wouldn't give that to
them which I lived for we don't know
anything about like where these two
stand especially like now even in real
life like there was the
the report that they had broken up but
nobody knows if that's true apparently
someone said on a podcast like yesterday
or the day before that after Raquel
heard that Ariana you know told on watch
Robin's live that she was sending Tom
letters to the house
um Raquel sent another letter to the
house addressed to Ariana with a
lightning bolt on it
I don't I try I'm trying to stay in like
the truthful actual non it's so hard
sphere it's hard because then also
things come from the rumor-based sphere
that turn out to be true and it's like
oh maybe I should have been paying
attention the whole time but like I
can't
I can't process all of these little
things that may or may not be true so
everybody's like talking about this
bombshell and when I saw the preview for
part three they said you have to wait to
the last five minutes like something
happens like everyone says like Raquel
is pregnant like all this stuff I
thought last night when Sheena was
wrapping up I thought she was actually
going to tell us she's pregnant and I
was like oh that's so sweet Oh I thought
maybe the
what was actually surprising was that
Raquel dropped the restraining order
yeah yeah
um but what do you think this bombshell
is
people said that the bombshell was that
Lisa Vanderpump knew the whole time Lisa
Vanderpump debunked that on Twitter a
couple of days no way she knew the whole
time no there's no way what could it be
and it's really being kept Under Wraps
I just think it's going to be
disappointing yeah I think so too
yeah
yeah well we'll find out next week
we'll find out next week
um that's like after that like
scandival's over like yeah but after
that then everyone can do more
interviews and stuff and like talk about
what's going on now and I think it'll be
like a another wave of scannable
information because as much as all the
cast members are talking about it and
doing their podcast and other people's
podcasts like they've had to refrain
from saying some stuff but I think once
the reunion's truly over like we'll get
more yeah they're limited right now
well that's your show tomorrow
um is Friday I just wanted everyone to
know that and we will be doing Audio
Only again so just stay with us next
week is up in the air but Jackson Claude
Audio Only is so good enough for me
truly
I love you dearly love you dearly and
we'll see you tomorrow for the big day
of the fry thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast on Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a thumbs up we're also available
video I already guess my business
hope you guys have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow bye love you bye